-Adam, pull the mic,
and let's see what you get.
Whoa!
All right.
Karaoke.
Wheel of Musical Impressions.
-Oh!
-Okay.
-♪ Wheel of
Musical Impressions ♪
♪ Wheel of Musical Impressions ♪
-For this one,
you'll get an artist,
and then you have
to sing a song
while doing
an impression of them.
Let's see what you get here.
"The Muffin Man" by Cher.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
All right. Do you --
Do you have a Cher in you?
Do you have...
Oh, right, very nice.
That's good.
-I got it. I got it. I got it.
-You got it. Jam Band.
-I got it. Okay.
-Jam Band...
can you give us something
with a Cher feel?
-Oh, yeah. Let's do it.
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-♪ Muffin man, muffin man,
muffin man, muffin man ♪
♪ Muffin man ♪
Ha!
♪ Do you know the muffin man? ♪
♪ Oh, Do you know
the muffin man? ♪
♪ Oh, do you know ♪
♪ The muffin man? ♪
♪ The muffin man,
the muffin man ♪
♪ That lives on Drury Lane, oh ♪
♪ Oh, do you know
the muffin man? ♪
♪ The muffin man
that lives on Drury Lane, oh ♪
♪ Oh, do you know
the muffin man? ♪
[ Laughs ]
♪ Oh, do you know
the muffin man? ♪
♪ The muffin man
that lives on Drury Lane, oh ♪
-Oh, my.
-Whoo!
That was great.
-How do you do that?
How do you make that good?
Cher would be very proud.